[Music]
sustainability is key it's not meant to
be a privilege it's more than selling
your products in the market it's about
being good stewards of the planet that
we live on and protecting the resources
that are out there we can't just have a
few people working on it and then other
people saying okay they're working on it
we don't have to everyone needs to work
together whether you're recycling at
home are watching how much water you use
means lots of little things can add up
to a big change
[Music]
clean drinking what is quite important
western Kenya is a very rich area in
terms of range but unfortunately most of
this rain goes into rivers that are not
protected people wash their clothes in
the same water they will take the
animals to drink water from those same
rivers by the time the people at the
bottom of the hill get access to that
water it's quite contaminated method
water is one of the main ingredients in
our product so we look to develop
techniques that can offset the usage in
the beginning we set a goal for a LEED
Platinum certification to be an
ecologically advanced factory to reduce
our carbon footprint we've got a
greenhouse on the roof we look at
sustainability from how can we have our
business and really minimize its impact
on the environment but also even be
restorative to the environment
styrofoam actually when it gets to
landfills it takes a long time to
decompose the Eco bin was a robotics
team project at first we decided to go
talk to the people at friendship village
they told us that styrofoam was one of
their biggest problems and so we
invented a wave Mignogna toxic glue we
pour our solution of deline manin and
other chemicals onto it and we reduced
it to one twentieth of its size it's
very easy to work with kids because
they're good agents of change they will
go back home and teach their own parents
Plaistow walk through ultra filtration
it holds back all the microorganisms and
the clean water is filled out I love my
job because it answers for me the
question why seeing their faces when
they see the difference in the water is
an honor for me
I've got a lot of pride for being here
where I started there was nothing on
this site we chose to be part of the
local community and see how methods
investment could positively impact the
community that we reside in as kids it
was always later on in life we could
have a big future it turns out that you
can accomplish big things now it doesn't
have to be later on it's rewarding
you're not just here to make soap this
is the only planet that we have so it's
important for us to take care of that
and have it there for future generations
[Music]